hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 29 2022
2022 what's going on how are ya
oh my god
was that the last weekend of the summer
or is it technically labor day
is labor day the last weekend of the
summer you know i'm excited about i'm
looking at my hotel window
i'm in a casino in maryland right now
and i just saw a southwest jet landing
so i was thinking to myself does that
mean the airport is really close
you know but you never know where
southwest because those [ __ ]
will land anywhere
you know
i mean that in a good way you know they
go to the alternative airport
you know the mom and pop one where you
can show up with like a gun in your bag
and they don't figure it out till uh i
don't know you got your [ __ ] gun out
on the plane or some [ __ ] um like you
can go instead of going to dallas the
main one you go to dallas love field
just like jfk but you don't rent a
convertible
right
you actually drive you know a little
faster
um
that would be awesome
i'm going home everybody oh my god thank
friggin christ
i mean as much as i enjoyed it out here
i have not been home since august 8th
and i've had enough this is my last big
run
of the year
all right then we're going to call him
old billy slowdown
hola
billy around the house
you know well pitter-patter
i'm gonna be walking around my pajama
bottoms my slippers
i
ain't doing [ __ ]
i
ain't doing [ __ ] which means i'll be
editing the last bit of the movie
[ __ ] but it's gonna be done
and then that's gonna be it
and then i
am going to [ __ ] i keep saying this
but
every time i it's like
it's like walking up to a mountain right
you think it's there and then it's it's
another hundred yards okay another
hundred yards why is it still way the
[ __ ] away
um
yeah it's just gonna be me a little bit
of football
playing with my kids
and that is gonna be it um
that's it all right and i know you guys
are probably sick of hearing me saying
this [ __ ]
but i'm just saying it so i just keep
saying no to [ __ ] so i'm not doing [ __ ]
so i can do the [ __ ] that i want to do
that's basically it so
um
with that college football started
this weekend and i i i landed out here
in maryland and i saw a little bit of
big ten action i watched the second half
of nebraska
versus northwestern and it was like last
year's football season never ended i
picked up right where i left off being
the old man
screaming at the tv why the [ __ ] would
you do that
if somebody
somebody can explain to me why nebraska
scored that touchdown went up by
whatever the [ __ ] they went up by
i'm an old man i can't remember the
score and then the f their next [ __ ]
move in the middle of the third quarter
is you kicking on side kick
you know pushing all your chips in going
all in
you have the [ __ ] momentum
northwestern recovers the ball bing bang
boom they go right down the [ __ ]
field
and i'm i i blame john madden video
games
everybody is just i don't know these
[ __ ] analytic these [ __ ] nerds who
never who didn't even get picked in gym
class have figured out mathematically
that this is a better thing to do
which it must be if it works out
mathematically
you know if mathematics involved is
involved
now we're talking about science
right
and all the good science not the science
that's paid for by a lobby
right
the science that is open-minded
is there such a thing i don't know
are human beings open-minded i don't
know if god knows i'm not um
i try to be
i try to be empathetic
um
mathematics involves science and science
is like
this is the answer because we can prove
it right until someone comes along and
says well you know what i don't think
you're right
because this shows this and then they're
supposed to be like well you don't say
that's what science claims
that's what they claim they are you know
like they act like
they're a little bit better like you
know science
versus religion is like chiropractors
versus masseuse
okay there's there's some respect with
both parties but each
person thinks that they're doing a
little bit more
right each person thinks that they have
you know like the way chiropractors
probably think that they have the back
a little more figured out than a
masseuse and a masseuse is kind of like
well you know
they can only do so much where they stop
i pick up and then the chiropractors are
like well actually where they stop we
pick up and then masseuse goes excuse me
and then the pirate pressure goes exc
you are excused
and they're like you want to take this
outside and then they're both like well
we don't want to fight because we'll
[ __ ] up our backs
i think that's how a chiropractic
masseuse fight goes down i think so
i was watching that on the masseuse
channel
which i'm sure there is at this point
the masseuse app
um
i guess the nerds
i guess if you can't catch a ball you
have time to figure out mathematically
what the ball does
right
as opposed to people who actually have
to carry catch throw or swat a ball
you know they're too busy [ __ ]
screaming like they're they're they're
about ready to run down a hill in
braveheart they don't have time
to add fractions to figure out that
evidently the right [ __ ] move
was not to kick the [ __ ] ball all the
way to the other side of the field
and make northwestern
you know try to go the whole length of
the field and hopefully you'll stop them
you'll get the ball back
and you'll take their [ __ ] hot
right
mathematics says you go for it
you kick the [ __ ]
onside kick you catch them off guard i
don't know what the deal is
i don't know what the deal is but like
that kind of like
decision to me
you know i don't gamble but you know you
like those [ __ ] season gamblers and
they're playing blackjack and they're
sitting next to some [ __ ] like me
who doesn't really know how to play and
then at some point they start screaming
that you're taking all my cards
um
which is my favorite thing in the world
i'm not taking any of your [ __ ] cards
this is a game of chance
all right stop acting like you're in
rounders and you got some sort of system
all right if you had a [ __ ] system
you would have figured out your life and
you wouldn't be a professional gambler
all right
you gamble for fun with some something
that you can afford first of all if
you're a professional gambler how you're
not a professional gambler if i can sit
down next to you
all right i can't go out there and line
up against a professional football
player can i i don't think i can well
sure i could go down there for a second
and then security would tackle me
maybe that guy in the pittsburgh
steelers would pick me up and body slam
me i don't [ __ ] know um anyway so
they [ __ ] on side this goddamn kick
give the ball right back to [ __ ]
northwestern and then northwestern goes
down and scores and nebraska never got
the [ __ ] lead back and they end up
losing the game
the huskers
lost
to to to to a [ __ ] team
that you know it doesn't eat corn you
know they're in the middle of chicago
evidently
northwestern which is weird to me
it shouldn't be called this is this is
like an old school 80s junk why are they
called northwestern when they're in the
midwest shouldn't be called midwestern
did mid just seem too like normal like
middle of the pack
let's say north
so it seems higher
north is not higher
okay it's on a map it is but like on in
reality
it's just north
listen i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about either i have been on the
road i've been out here for [ __ ] ever
and um
yeah i don't understand why
i would have this gigantic show
in boston
and then i wouldn't get a break
afterwards i'm kind of confused as to
why it was like did you enjoy that great
now work the next six days in a [ __ ]
row
um
was it hard was it hard to come down
after a show of that magnitude oh there
was no problem whatsoever
i got a plane to canada the next day and
we all acted like it never [ __ ]
happened
it already seems like it was 20 years
ago
but here's the upside the upside of
traveling the way i am is you get so
[ __ ] sick of your act last night i
think i riffed like a half hour
i just like abandoned my act
i started thinking the jokes i'm like i
don't want to say that again
you know what i mean
it's like
you know when you know you're going to
quit your job
you just pull up one day and you're
sitting in your car and you're just but
your body literally won't let you get
out of the car
it's like i
physically cannot
get my brain
to have me reach for that door handle
open it up
you know i mean maybe i can open up the
door and maybe i'll start walking but
i'm not walking towards that
establishment i am done
with that establishment and it's funny
because nobody in there knows you are
nobody knows that you're that sick of it
because you've been putting on a [ __ ]
phony smile like you do in every picture
hey let's take a picture right no matter
what mood you're in you're like jeez
i want to kill myself hey hey can i get
a picture absolutely
[Applause]
having a good time
i've i've figured out life
you know back in the day you know those
[ __ ] old pictures back when the guy
you know
looked like he was looking under
somebody's dress before he took a
picture there was a small explosion
nobody smiled
i mean they just sat there and they just
however they were feeling you just got
that look on their face
i mean maybe they were just sitting
there going where the [ __ ] did the
photographer go
why is he under that thing and i'm not
under anything and there's going to be
an explosion maybe that's the reason why
people had that look on their face
you know
maybe life was harder
i don't i don't have no idea it must
have been harder everything was [ __ ]
hard he had to figure [ __ ] out
you know what was a [ __ ] back in
the day he was having a toothache
oh my god i mean it was literally like
that's when like one of your parents
came in with some sort of farming tool
all right open up let's see what we got
going on here
all right
quit you crying
quit your crying before i have you
[ __ ] trampled by an oxen
and that's the way it was in america 19
[ __ ] oh one
19 ought one
um
are you guys like me if there's not
video footage and it's about history you
can't watch it
i think when there's like a picture
somebody just draws a picture of what
they think happened
from a couple hundred years ago and
there's some guy narrating it as they
slowly panned to the right in the
picture
you know to give me the idea like it was
videotaped like it actually happened
you know and then jesus with his dirty
feet walked up to a leper right and
somebody painted a picture of it and
then they just slowly you know pan you
see jesus
you know forever with his just his arms
open
um
anyway
jam band jesus that's my favorite jesus
you know
jam band jesus
i don't know which jesus you like
i don't like the one that's like
hovering and he's looking down sad i
like jam band jesus
you know where he looks like he went to
a rock festival and got charged too much
money for water
right
which by the way as much [ __ ] is you
know if you swatch that woodstock 99
documentary i kind of
googled some [ __ ] on that they
this kind of makes sense but they never
really talk about it
um
you know they kind of make it seem like
woodstock was like this giant festival
and it came and it happened man and it
was like they were going to charge money
right man and then like
all these [ __ ] groovy hippies snuck
in like the pieces of [ __ ] that they
were
you know just like this groovy happy
it's a bunch of [ __ ] crooks
that's what went to that [ __ ] thing
the cheap pricks i mean how much was it
what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't
take a bath
and then sneaks into the concert and
stinks it all up no wonder it was
outside
jesus [ __ ] christ you imagine if they
had that in a goddamn arena
i'll tell you right now people couldn't
have snuck in just walking through cow
pastures as [ __ ]
and their [ __ ] sandals bitching about
richard nixon the whole way and what a
crook he is as they sneak into the
[ __ ] festival right so anyway all of
those people showed up um
oh can we see music festival i'm trying
to be
and then they act like nothing ever
happened again
here we go i'm trying to look this up as
i'm telling you about
they act like nothing ever happened
again which which like makes no sense
it makes no sense that
people who try to make money off of
other people would see all those people
show up
and there would never be another giant
festival like that evidently there was
people were like well hey man like what
if we had our own [ __ ] woodstock man
except we got these
dirty stinky hippies who don't want to
[ __ ] pay for [ __ ] as they [ __ ] about
the man to come in and actually have to
pay
right
there was that going on and then there
was also conservative america
slash people who take showers
it wears shoes
[Music]
and when they go to a concert they go
into
you know
a venue
and they actually pay to go in
where they steal is at work from poorer
people when they whatever the [ __ ]
business they all do it they all [ __ ]
do it the liberals do it and the
conservatives do it it's why
conservatives to me are less annoying
because
there's no lying in what they do in
their lives they're like yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] rape you where the [ __ ]
liberals are just like hey man like
we're all in this together we're like
we're all fan we're all family you know
man and then they [ __ ] rip you off
it's it's better if someone's just [ __ ]
right out of the gate which is this this
is why i do my podcast
you know
just wire to wire cuntiness
so anyway after like woodstock
in in 1970 they did a number of
festivals they did the same [ __ ] happen
right so
um
they want to have another music festival
all right so i guess like the groovy
people were looking at woodstock like
wow man that's like far out man can you
like imagine being out there man and
like not have to pay for [ __ ] and like
get [ __ ] for free wouldn't that be
awesome and conservative america is like
we don't want a bunch of dirty [ __ ]
people coming in here
a bunch of goddamn dirty white people
coming in here doing their [ __ ] drugs
[ __ ] out in the open walking around
with their pubes and pubiscuses and
pubic bones and and genitalia's out
all right [ __ ] that [ __ ] so
meanwhile the man's like well how do we
make money
for these filthy children
um
so what they did was they started
festivals
and then immediately once the
conservative people
people with the shoes on right and
wallets and stuff like that right
soap they're like you're not having that
dirty [ __ ] in our [ __ ] town all right
this is a god fair in town jesus is
white like us and we don't want
anybody with pigment and that includes
mud
on their skin that's how white we are
there's even white people that we don't
like right
so they're like [ __ ] you guys you're not
doing that [ __ ] here so then the people
putting together the festival they had
to switch up the name they couldn't say
it was a music pop festival whatever so
there was this festival called the erie
canal soda pop festival
you know and they did it at this
in griffin indiana
all right and the capacity of whatever
the hell they were having it
was 55 000 people
and they said it was a soda pop festival
now i don't know what kind of [ __ ]
rubes were living in that town that
thought 55 000 people were gonna go up
to a soda pop festival when you can get
[ __ ] soda
anywhere all right you know i just
realized you know on the east coast they
call it soda and towards the midwest
they call it pop you want some pop
hey bill you want some pop all right
and i'd be like you mean soda
and like soda that's all
what's all
all oil oh oil
yeah
he won't sell you want all
um
i just realized soda pop i never put
those two things together
he went to pap
um pop actually makes more sense because
it's fizzy right
i know i'm all over the place well you
go [ __ ] yourself all right you you
travel around you travel around the
goddamn heartland okay telling [ __ ]
jokes for [ __ ] week at my age
all right
i'm i'm in survival mode right now so
anyway so they call it the erie canal
soda pop festival so it doesn't sound
like a bunch of dirty white people who
don't want to pay for a ticket are going
to show up but that's exactly what
happened
it's also known as the bull island rock
festival it was a rock festival held on
labor day
weekend
of 1972 near griffith indiana on bull
island on a strip of land in illinois
but on the indiana side of the wabash
river
so they thought 55 000 people were gonna
show up right so probably
everyone's thinking like you know
woodstock happened and i missed it man
right
and then like
it's like
morrison was dead janice joplin was dead
jimi hendrix was dead at this point so
they're probably like all right it's
gonna be a bunch of new [ __ ] people
man
we can say that we were there before
they all [ __ ] don't deed man and
we're not gonna pay and all of this [ __ ]
right
so [ __ ]
anywhere from 200 to 300 000 people
showed up and they had like eight
bathrooms and they were saying it was
the equivalent of having one bathroom at
[ __ ] yankee stadium
and it went the exact same way as
woodstock 99. it was the first day of
like this hey man this doesn't seem like
it's being run right but we're here
right man we're [ __ ] far out where
are you from rock on man peace and love
man right
i don't even know if any of this [ __ ]
happened it's just
it's just how i feel it went down and
then by the second day
you know the what the [ __ ] emotions
started settling in and then by the end
they just burned the whole [ __ ] place
down that's exactly what happened and
someone was trying to claim
that at woodstock 99 some old [ __ ]
rocker was running around on the last
day
telling everybody you better get out of
here this is gonna be another bull
island and everyone was like what the
[ __ ] is that guy talking about and you
know what he got the dude i called it
so anyway
like
i think like three or four people
drowned
probably because they were trying
to bathe over the three days the
festival drifted steady into chaos
food and water were in short supply a
torrential rain soaked the festival by
the way god hates rock festivals
i don't think god likes peace either and
that's why i think he made us the way we
are we are psychotic warlike people
and it goes from the humans all the way
down to the [ __ ] animals to insects
everybody is [ __ ] killing everybody
on this [ __ ] planet i don't know why
we think it's any anywhere different i
don't know a torrential rain soaked the
festival a truck bringing food into the
festival was hijacked looted and burned
[ __ ] peace and love man until i don't
have food for a day and a half then i
turn into a [ __ ]
vigilante uh when some vendors
overcharged for food and drinks the
crowd turned over many of the rvs and
robbed the vendors [ __ ] man man
um i gotta be honest with you if if why
the [ __ ] would you ever go to a rock
festival every year when they have that
goddamn coachella
and all of the coachella whatever the
fight said coachella
because
coachella right why the [ __ ]
i understand young people that is such a
young person thing to go to
you know you don't have any money
so you don't give a [ __ ] about your
clothes why do you care if you're
tripping laying in the mud in the grass
or in the [ __ ] desert heat but
anybody over the age of 25
that goes to coachella
you know you know what the worst is is
now when they go to those things
the richie riches that go there and they
like fly in by helicopter and they have
wristbands and [ __ ] and they sit there
in an air-conditioned little [ __ ] pod
as they look down as the raping and
drugging and all of that shit's going on
people drowning and [ __ ]
we're up here we were there man
[ __ ] up there getting botox shots if
somebody's downstairs [ __ ] oh dean
is that dragging him into a pop tent um
i don't know why anybody would ever go
to one of those [ __ ] things
hey man
do you want to stand outside for three
days
[Music]
around people that have no business not
having clothes on
i mean why don't you just stay home and
listen to the album or whatever the [ __ ]
it is you listen to your phone
you know i think that would be a lot
nicer
than actually going there people are
going to videotape it
right
you know what's funny uh i can't say
this but this this somebody who does
that
with like war
like there's certain people that keep
showing up at wars
you know like that's their rock festival
[Music]
instead of staying home and watching it
on the news
um
anyway uh on the sun on sunday evening
some starving festival goers killed a
local's cow that was still on the island
but did not have any means of butchering
it
uh so they just killed a [ __ ] cow uh
drugs were freely available in a
makeshift shopping district where
dealers openly displayed their illegal
goods numerous bans quickly cancelled
and three concert goers drowned in the
wabash river
as the festival ended what was left of
the crowd destroyed the music stand by
fire the promoters later explained that
they had sold 30 000 advanced tickets
for 20 to 25 each and had estimated a
crowd of no more than 55 000 would
attend thus they were completely
unprepared when more than 200 000 people
showed up now how could you be
unprepared after that already happened
in woodstock
following the concert the promoters were
subjected to multiple lawsuits by the
owner of bull island the vendors the
internal revenue service the state of
illinois and the state of indiana
the court found the promoters to be in
contempt of court and fined them several
thousand dollars all right well several
thousand dollars
they sold a gross 600 to 700 grand
yeah that [ __ ] shell out a couple of
grand [ __ ] state of illinois in
indiana
coming in to get some [ __ ] money they
didn't give a [ __ ] what happened
i don't believe any of that
well what happened there was deplorable
but if you give us fifteen hundred
dollars we'll forget all about the dead
bodies
um
do you know when i was in saint louis
one time
when i checked out of a hotel they
charged me an occupation tax
they taxed me for occupying a hotel room
like i was selling goods out of it i
didn't i just used it for what it was
for that's just one of those it's just a
complete 100
[ __ ] shakedown
you know our ticket master is up to the
roll tricks
what is it now is it like 40 000 to see
bruce springsteen in like the [ __ ]
200th row
um
that whole thing i like how scalping has
become like professional now like
literally the website that sells tickets
is now scalping
um
and why
why don't the politicians step in
why don't they step in i'll tell you why
because the money that they make scalp
and tickets they then [ __ ] probably
peel off and stuff it into their front
coat pockets and they they pay for their
trip to epstein island
oh there it is i figured it all out
so anyway uh i had a great time i got i
was in uh reading pennsylvania
which i was talking about on the
anything better podcast
so if you want to hear my uh some of my
stories from that i'm not trying to do
that [ __ ] i didn't mean to do that
what man you're going to bring up a
topic and then make me go listen to
another podcast you have your bald
orange [ __ ] what if i am what if i've
gone totally corporate america on you
now i'm going delta airlines on you uh
you thought you were in the first group
we we we've created another group ahead
of that group
you go chase that [ __ ] carrot for a
while
um who do i have to blow to get on this
[ __ ] plane within the first 300
people is the number one question asked
at a delta gate
um
no reading was uh
was amazing just great people same thing
like buffalo but i really liked reading
pennsylvania and it was a beautiful town
that is going through a lot of tough
times
and for all these [ __ ] patriotic
douchebags out there you know wearing
their american eagle [ __ ] shirts and
[ __ ] america and all that and all
these liberal [ __ ] out in hollywood
that act like they give a [ __ ] it's the
fact that we just
i don't know
don't have the time to help really just
help people out like there was so many
people that i saw when i was down there
lit
that just needed help
but you know
how
i'm going to say capitalism every form
of government how it works is you have
to be
constantly running or you're going to
get trampled so you can't even stop and
help some if you go to stop and try to
pick somebody up then you get [ __ ]
trampled is the way the game is set up
that way you don't have the time to
rebel against the [ __ ] that are making
you run that's my theory
now i'm not good at math so there's no
analytics involved there so i'm sure
it's [ __ ] up on some level but like i
walked down the street in reading
pennsylvania it was one of my favorite
gigs of the year by the way an amazing
venue
this little um
what was it i think maybe i talked about
this on thursday i think i did sorry my
head's spinning it's just an amazing
venue but dude walking downtown and
reading at like 10 in the [ __ ]
morning to get coffee i immediately felt
like i needed my head on a [ __ ]
swivel
you know what i mean you know when
you're walking down the street you just
feel a little too shiny and new
and people looking like who the [ __ ]
that guy and uh
why does he look like he's eating
healthy
um
i don't know
i don't know but i really
enjoyed
even though i was walking down the
street it was kind of scary and
everything was a lot of great people
there same thing with buffalo buffalo
great people and before i went to the
airport
um
i uh
well before i went to show i got some
wings
and this great little sports bar
that had like the jerseys of the french
connection
from the 70s with the buffalo sabres
they had all the uh buffalo bills you
know cornelius bennett thurman thomas
jim kelly even like a jim kelly houston
gambler's shirt on the wall
um great wings the [ __ ] onions were
ridiculous i'm trying to find the name
of the [ __ ] place i'll figure it out
probably say it on the next podcast
uh shout out to them they were super
nice
um
and before i went to the airport i went
by charlie the butcher
got a great roast beef sandwich
and uh my only and then i also did a
little walk
around buffalo that was my cardio for
the day i did that in the morning
and i walked around their minor league
ballpark which is [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
uh my only problem was i went to go buy
a cigar in this place
and the guy goes you in the system i
said no i'm not no no i'm not no i'm not
no i'm not in system and
i said no i'm not and he goes do you
have an id so whenever i have an id i
hold on to it so the guy ended up taking
it out of my hand and he goes to scan it
and i put my hand over so he would
couldn't scan it i go what are you doing
he goes i have to see if your id is real
so i said i said i don't want to be in
the system and i quickly i took it down
i took it down i said listen man i
understand
you know you didn't create this you're
just doing your job i'm sorry i'll put
these cigars back i don't want to do
that
and you know it was a little tense
and then i i commented because they had
these humor doors that i liked they had
like an american flag on them kind of
look cool
and i was like who makes those those are
cool he said uh you know i don't know
whatever i said all right have a nice
day and i walked out
and then
then i said all the [ __ ] that i was
gonna say in that that usually escalates
which has been happening to me lately
and that would have been the third time
third time you got to look at what the
[ __ ] you're doing so i made sure i
didn't say that but i did walk away
you know
muttering like a son of a [ __ ] like
what do you mean you gotta [ __ ] scan
it to see if it's real just look at it
it's a [ __ ] id
you don't need to scan it
or you gotta make sure that i'm [ __ ]
21 look at me i look like a [ __ ]
lobster fisherman you know i'm [ __ ]
over 21. i know what you're doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] always trying to take
information from you i'm buying a
[ __ ] cigar i'm not gonna scan my
[ __ ] driver's license
it's my only problem
anyway
so uh
other than that i had a great experience
there and uh i had fun
you know talking to the
the bills fans in the crowd i'm saying
you know you guys got a good team and i
was ta this is
i was being 100 honest with him telling
him
when they
do one of those nfl films about the
buffalo bills going to four super bowls
in a row and losing all four
and they do it from the fans perspective
i shut it off like i can't sit there
and watch that level of pain and i was
joking that they should show that that
highlight right after they they do like
starving children around the world
war-torn countries and then like buffalo
bills
sitting there going like i mean there's
literally people that went to all four
because after they lost the first year
and you blew all that money as a working
class person and they go the next year
they're like they're going to win this
year they're going to win this year and
then they lose again and then they go
again now you're like in now you're
chasing your money you're like well i
know if i don't go then they're going to
go
and i'm going to bubble and they win
again and then they go the fourth time
like there's no [ __ ] way they're
going to lose this fourth time and then
they did i mean these people literally
lost a down payment on a house
out there i mean
unreal it's still an amazing achievement
to go there four times in a row but what
sucks is no one appreciates it and then
you just get [ __ ] for it
so um
i worked with uh dean delray and joe
bartnick in uh reading
and in buffalo and then uh
maryland here and working with todd rex
so i've been having a good time and they
actually brought a uh
a drum kit in
today
it was kind of funny there was like a
zillion workers like walking around
and uh i was kind of psyched i used to
get self-conscious if there was a bunch
of [ __ ] people around staring at me
while i'm playing now i don't even give
a [ __ ]
um
i still sound like [ __ ] though
but
i did get a couple of practices in here
all right let's let's do the reads for
this week xiaohui all right
indochito
you know finding the perfect suit
is impossible
but finding a suit that's perfect for
you
is simple thanks to indochino
choose your favorite fabric and
customize every detail define the look
that's perfect for you submit your
measurements online or get
measure in store
for a custom sorry made for you fit at
an incredible price
and with their fall collection
featuring new colors and premium fabrics
you'll be in style all season long every
indochino suit is made just for you it's
a tailored experience at a great price
design a look that suits you perfectly
from the fabric to the cut
shop they're made for for you suits
starting at just
449
and premium
fitted shirts starting at just 89
uh you can fine tune every detail lapels
linings monograms and more get a premium
personalized wardrobe without spending a
fortune
shop custom fitted shirts casual wear
outerwear and more
uh they're always adding new designs and
fabric options like their latest fall
connection ready to evalu evaluate your
look even further indochino lets you
make any
suit a tux
what
ready to elevate
your look further indochino lets you
make any suit a tux
what does that mean how does a suit
become a tuxedo
it's like one of those [ __ ] trucks
that turns into a robot like the
haberdashery version design your perfect
suit with indochino take 50 bucks off
any purchase at 3.99 or more use promo
code burr b-u-r-r at indochino.com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burr
oh look who it is everybody it's solo
stove
solo stove you know life's best moments
happen around a roaring fire
in a smokeless pit well yeah obviously
i've mentioned before if that roaring
fire is under control
you know
you never run faster than when you're
around a roaring fire are you looking to
drop weight get a solo stove a smokeless
fire pit from solo stove makes your
outdoor moments even more memorable
would you like to cook your meth in a
quaint way solo stove
because instead of having a cup to
constantly dodge campfire fumes that is
the [ __ ] worst you can sit back relax
and enjoy the fire you know something
everybody's getting ready to have your
back door little outdoor [ __ ]
excursion there to watch football
outside you know
you know a lot of people on the east
coast where they have all four seasons
you know it starts to get a little
colder right and all of a sudden you
have to go inside and you get sad
because you're having your last outdoor
thing what if you have a solo stuff you
can stay out there all goddamn day long
like a [ __ ] rescue dog
when you get taken out of a [ __ ]
waiting to get rescued
you know
uh upgrade your backyard with the solo
stove fire pit and create a s and create
story worthy moments
without the fireside fumes stainless
steel construction designed to regulate
airflow and burn more efficiently man
solo stove fire pits are brilliant
brilliantly engineered to be easy to use
and they're built to last easy to light
with a few bits of stata your fire is
blazing in minutes so they're so
confident you'll love it they offer a
lifetime warranty and a 30-day free
return policy right now you can get a
you can get big discounts on all fire
pits during solo stove's labor day sale
and use the promo code burr at
solostove.com for an extra ten dollars
off that's solostove.com promo code bur
for ten dollars off on their incredible
labor day discounts but hurry the labor
day sale
um ends september 11th
um
all right here we go oh look who it is
they always they're always batting
cleanup it's the one and only zip
crew
hiring is challenging
especially always start with just some
big
you know i'm
frustrated everything you have all the
copy starts that way don't you why i
want to feel faith
don't you hate going out in the backyard
and you burn your toes it's frustrating
hiring is challenging everyone
especially right now when you have so
much on your plate
what are they talking about overeating
what are they talking about here luckily
how am i supposed to hire anybody when i
got this pile of wings in front of me
luckily there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple fast and smart
um others just meant hiring simple like
you're just going to hire dumb people
they're simple people good people put
their pants on one leg at a time
a place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
ziprecruiter.com you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply zip
[Music]
is so effective that four to five
employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day uh no wonder
is the number one rated hiring site
based on g2 satisfaction ratings as of
january 1st 2022 and right now to try
zipper you can try ziprecruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
burr that's it
the smartest way to hire hire
uh hawaii okay
oh i'm sorry who i was like what the
[ __ ] this hawaii little league team
have to do with anything
this is a uh this is
this is a letter oh that [ __ ] up the i
love my this is my favorite line of any
copy sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
all right i paused too long but i always
feel like a professional
just the way that's written you know i
always point too you know like you guys
are looking at me i pointed the smartest
way to hire
i gave you a little wink got my hand in
my slacks pocket
you know
exposing my smart belt all right
now it's time for this [ __ ] that you
guys wrote
this segment is called the [ __ ] that you
guys wrote
and bill tries to read it without
stumbling all right hawaii little league
team dear bill please give a shout out
to our little league team hawaii does
not have a professional sports team
i wondered what would happen if we did
well who's your little league team
are you guys doing something in the
little league world series now i have to
google this [ __ ]
jesus christ what are you too busy
living in paradise to give me all the
[ __ ] information i need
all right hawaii little league
2022
what do we got here the league world
series
little league world series
hawaii has enjoyed one of the most
dominant runs in little league world
history get the [ __ ] out of here all
right congratulations literally
a little league in hawaii and it capped
off the fourth
title in state history and yet another
dominant victory backed by six runs
driven in by kama
angel angela sorry if i said that wrong
and 10 strikeout performance from
geron lancaster or jaron lancaster or
jaron land kaster
hawaii blew away
caraceo
did you just want me to read this [ __ ]
so i'd sound stupid 13-3 winning it
winning by a 10-run rule walk-off single
from angel in the bottom of the fourth
why was it out of the went out of its
way
was it out of a way what hawaii wasn't
out away from ceiling you get it hawaii
seal sealing the victory in the top of
the fourth but a two-run single by
jathan cordia
brought the score to 12 to three keeping
their all right we got it they [ __ ] did
they win the whole thing
that's awesome well shout out to you
guys congratulations
congratulations and continued success
oh boy we're talking about pizza here
chicago pizza
in particular you know what it's it's
time
it's time for an adult beverage did i
mention i started drinking again
i almost made four years
what do you want now i'm drinking in the
afternoon by myself while i'm doing a
podcast
oh it's delicious
tastes even better when you come back
i'm kidding i'm drinking water
i'm drinking
liquid death
uh chicago pizza hey billy sherbert
shack
sir sherbet sack sorry
sherbert sack what is that oh it's the
color of sherbet oh you son of a [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious
billy sherbert sack i like that one
it's a little quirky i gotta do a little
math on that one
um i don't eat sherbet i don't
understand what sherbert's supposed to
be
um sherbert you know what they should
call it disappointing ice cream
[Music]
oh wow did you get me some ice cream
what the [ __ ] am i eating
it's sherbert it is you know what
actually sherbet
sherbet is i thought it was sherbert
have i mean i thought there was another
r in it hang on a second have i been
saying that wrong my whole life
sherbert maybe i just wanted it to rhyme
sherbert
ice cream
oh my god there's not another in it
am i saying it right
sherbet pronunciate my whole life i've
said sherbet you want some sherbet there
we go
sherbet
sherbet it's sherbet
sherbet oh [ __ ]
sherbet sack
i thought it was sherbet no one's ever
corrected me
you want some sherbet i'd be like no i
want some ice sherbet
sherbet
well it does say bet
i swear to god i don't know if i have a
slight dyslexia no that that's the new
that's the new way of saying i have
dyslexia no you're a dumb [ __ ] bill all
right i'll go with that uh when you're
in chicago this november skip
the deep dish pizza joints
now i wanted a chicago ian a chaga would
whatever you guys call each other is it
chicago
or is it shy cargo no i don't i don't
think i say anything right i wanted
somebody tell me where the deep dish
place was to go this person is saying
that style is not from
the norm
oh it's not the norm for most local
chicagoans there it is
places like lou
malnet
malnutes
what the [ __ ] were these from like the
turn of the century or gino's east there
with cheeto
all right what the [ __ ] you doing which
are the typical touristy places to get
pizza are not the usual choices for
locals i couldn't agree with you more
about how the sauce is the star of the
show
probably the crust too yeah if the crust
is too thick you know in the end
you know it's all of a sudden somebody
gives you a [ __ ] loaf of bread why am
i doing that and the cheese is just to
complement the sauce and the crust
exactly
okay here you go we're getting the
inside scoop here i would hunt down two
places
uh pequod's pizza
p-q-u-o-d-s pizza pequod's is known for
their amazing caramelized crust pan
style pizza it is a thick pizza but not
a deep dish or stuffed style like the
joints mentioned above amazing sauce
amazing crust dude these are the kind of
solids
that that that you need
all right number two aurilio's pizza
see i like this
that's a good name aurelio
you know what i mean
if they're not making pizza they're one
of the five crime families
the aurelio crime family no kidding
aurelio pizza
a-u-r-e-l-i-o
orillios pizza aurelios has the best
sauce of all time period
well it's my favorite anyways
the sauce is a sweet style it's [ __ ]
amazing trust me although they have a
deep dish get the thin crust it's
chicago style which is cut into little
squares not into big triangle slices
like new york city it's not even new
york city it's like like every other
city all right good deal
i'm adding that to the places
to go
um
i go i'm turning am i turning into like
a food podcast
because now somebody's going to talk
about sugar
by turning it into food a food podcast
you'll know when that day happens
because the podcast intro will start
with that you know that generic
everything's gonna be okay music that
they play before a cooking show
like ah
hi i'm kathy kudwick and welcome
to another edition of mediterranean moms
and i'm gonna show you some of the the
the recipes from the old country
my family is greek and italian with a
little bit of portuguese spanish and
french
you lion [ __ ] you just named the whole
[ __ ] mediterranean so you can cast a
wide net what are you really huh you
from bulgaria
is that what it is
was your uncle a vampire
um is that what dracula was from by the
way
transylvania is a place you know what i
mean nowadays i will say this
if dracula was written today you could
not say he was from an actual place
because people get offended
are you saying we're a bunch of zombies
he was you know
how is you know with all these woke
douches out there how has dracula not
gotten canceled
i mean
i don't think i ever saw him hook up
with a chick consensually
right he comes over there with his whole
[ __ ] vibe he [ __ ] bites on their
necks
and he basically ruins their lives
um
yeah that whole thing with bought him
was just weird he just came in all this
[ __ ]
slick i mean this is dangerously close
to richard pryor talking about [ __ ]
dracula i'm going to stop here but i
mean that's basically
[Music]
when you watch remember that old richard
pryor the wino meet and dracula
um
all right your sugar rants
yo bill all those sugar and fatty rants
are spot on
what once the something that i said was
right that's amazing are the ones that
you
that i made reference to fat people go
to the doctors routinely but they're low
cost visits to health industry because
doctors can't do much for fat people
what are you talking about they can
[ __ ] make a living off of them giving
them medication
they give them lap band surgery you know
when they go in there with a [ __ ] wet
vac and suck all the fat out unless they
can
wait um
unless they can and then the fatties
have to pay for procedures when needed
oh all right i recently learned how
cancer detection works
and if it isn't the biggest
tell as far as cancers go i don't know
what is this is how they locate cancer
according to this person they locate
cancer by actually radiating sugar sugar
and adding dye to it
then they inject the radioactive sugar
into your system it travels to the
cancer
because sugar feeds cancer
every woo-woo cancer treatment in the
last 100 years
includes cutting sugar out completely
i swear to god i don't even unders it's
just
how did we get here
is the only way to make money by slowly
killing people that seems to be the
easiest way to make a lot of money
um
podcast question
dear billy gray bush
[Laughter]
i was recently
these are getting really personal guys i
know you're running out of ways to
insult me but you know
at least you taught me how to say
sherbet
i'm actually going to call my lovely
wife nia after this podcast
and be like how have you been letting me
say sherbert all these years
i'd be like i [ __ ] hate sherbert
and no one would say anything but then i
wonder afterwards like did that guy just
say sherbert
it's sherbet
not sherbet it's not a new [ __ ]
muppet you [ __ ] all right dear billy
greybush i was recently listening to
your podcast
when you brought up drinking and how
that is the easy way to go
to deal with your problems i don't think
i ever said that directly
um
i i don't know maybe uh what i was
saying was like that i don't i don't
know i don't even remember half the [ __ ]
i say
anyways this person says i've been a
booze bag and done some pretty
deplorable stuff since i was 18. i use
it to suppress my childhood problems but
i feel it's really time to quit and to
try to deal with that in a functional
way i don't want to be that old guy with
a massive nose yeah that's called a gin
blossom and a face the color of a beat
i'm 26 now and every time i stop
drinking my friends [ __ ] talk me about
how i'm not fun anymore should i risk
losing my friends to better my own life
uh
yeah i don't think you even have to lose
them just be like
yeah just like listen i'm gonna [ __ ]
die i don't i don't want to look like wc
fields when i'm [ __ ] 27.
um
look you can i i could just stop
drinking and then try to stay friends
with those people and if they're not
gonna be friends with you if alcohol was
the only reason why you're friends then
you need to get some new friends
unfortunately you're only 26 years old
so you got plenty of time
plenty of time to find new friends at my
age it's hard to find new friends
because um
you know most of your good ones are dead
and uh and then people my age that are
looking for friends it's usually because
they're [ __ ]
and they got kicked out in their 30s and
40s with people that should have been
their lifelong friends um anyways love
the podcast and what you bring to the
comedy scene thanks you thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself
um all right
i'm gradually learning how to speak
english during this podcast sherbet
sherbet and it's anyway not anyways
anyways
all right underrated
all right shopping for deals
um i make decent money if i spend
an extra thousand dollars a year on
groceries or everyday supplies
because i didn't price shop i'll still
be fine
uh after prices started inflating i
started looking around and realized no
stores no store has deals on everything
anymore you really have to look at
multiple stores i don't care if you need
to save money or not if you are giving
into the convenience of paying 4.99 for
dish stove dish soap instead of 1.99
you're a fool and are contributing to
the fall of civilization
well look at you you got it all figured
out don't you get tight [ __ ]
um
i'm going to tell you this right now you
know if you can afford to pay 4.99
instead of a dollar 99 and can you just
[ __ ] get the dish shelf that's right
in front of your face and not make an
extra goddamn trip
uh then actually live life
i would do that but you know
i i've been there okay
and i wasn't making money i would i
would just i just went to some [ __ ]
that smelled bad and was you know i went
to the you know the bodega around the
corner when i was living [ __ ]
in new york city that [ __ ] [ __ ]
used to mop it up with the same dirty
goddamn mop
i remember thinking like why doesn't he
just change the mop here what i should
have done is i should have just
gone over to the shelf and got some
bleach and poured it in there
and been like that it's still to this
day i can still smell it and that was
like 27 [ __ ] it's half my life ago
um
my place barbie doesn't even exist
anymore
that's the [ __ ] up thing
it's probably some glass tower
um
with talking heads from cnn and fox news
living in there
um
yeah you know what you're right i think
that sometimes because i'm terrible with
money like i don't spend a bunch of
money but i also don't give a [ __ ] i
shop like a guy or i'm just like i need
this are you selling this great what do
you want here that's how i shop i don't
go around
doing [ __ ] like that but i think you're
actually right that's why i kind of gave
you [ __ ] because i knew you were right
because i do that all the time i just
don't give a [ __ ] like
part of it is i'm like anti-social
and it's like now i have to go talk to
another person
now i have to walk into another store
and there's gonna be that security guard
who's like 108 years old
you know
what are we gonna admit that most of the
security can't do [ __ ] in this country
it's just they just have a person there
so they won't get sued and they just
hire somebody who got [ __ ] out of his
security money to [ __ ] stand there
you know and lean up against the goddamn
you know
display of dishwashing detergent
as you come on hey how are you
you're the security yeah
did you fight in the spanish-american
war how [ __ ] old are you oh jesus
bill that's ageism
just [ __ ] why would you stick an old
guy is he just putting another victim in
the store
um
unless they have unless they wire their
help i've fallen and i can't get up
button to the local police
maybe that's the way you do
it i don't know i have no idea um anyway
college football starts next week is
next week's game let's let's let's take
a peek here at the nfl schedule let's
take a peek
the nfl thursday night game right nfl
thursday
first game
schedule
when is it week one
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
all right thursday september 8th ah [ __ ]
me
it's not next thursday it's the thursday
after but look at that game would ya
josh allen and the buffalo bills
versus the rams
and that [ __ ] guy from detroit who i
already forget his name even though he
won his super bowl
what the [ __ ] was his name
the second the season's over see back in
the day i used to when i had football
cards i would just go through them like
flash cards
granted i wasn't flying all around the
[ __ ] country and having two kids and
[ __ ]
uh what the hell is
matthew stafford bam
got it
who else is playing oh would you look at
this would you look at this
would you look at this saints versus the
bengals browns at the panthers
49ers at the bears
steelers against the bengals look at
that
a big [ __ ]
divisional game right off the bat
eagles versus the lions
calls first to texans and look at this
look at this my new england patriots
with mac jones
is going up against the dolphins who
signed tyreek hill can we cover them
um the washington commanders
jesus [ __ ] the cleveland guardians the
washington commanders
what is that that sounds like one of
those both of them sound like names
of of sci-fi like space tv shows
there would be spin-offs from buck
rogers that would go half a season
you know lauren green stars in the
commanders
um
the new york football giants
against the tennessee titans
oh here's a fun one the chiefs versus
the cardinals
raiders chargers
jesus christ last time i watched a
ragers chargers game i was on mushrooms
it was [ __ ] amazing
um
packers versus vikings
buccaneers versus cowboys tom brady
going into dallas
oh my god there's gonna be a lot of
botox leaking after he [ __ ] drops 400
yards on them
and then he got the denver broncos
against the seattle seahawks that do not
have russell wilson wait a minute the
broncos have russell wilson and he's
going into seattle you're telling me
you're not going to sit down and watch
that
does anybody do it better than the nfl
as far as the show
i'm not talking about you know they take
care of their veterans the way this
country does um
shots fired
all right that's it
that's the [ __ ] podcast man
um i hope you enjoyed it thank you to
everybody that came out over the last
week
uh
in the last week i've performed to more
people than i've probably performed to
in my life without a doubt it was
unbelievable run
and i got one more show and i'm already
feeling like i'm gonna be in a stupid
mood
and and i wrote a couple jokes today i
didn't really write them down i just
they got them in my head you know i was
sitting outside
uh by the [ __ ] valet
and uh
enjoying myself having a [ __ ] root
beer and a little short cigar
and now i'm gonna head in i'm gonna do a
little [ __ ] damage there tonight
hopefully
um all right that is it
oh wait oh i gotta get give this buffalo
this buffalo coffee shop a shout out let
me see if i can at least find this
let me see best
coffee
in
buffalo
all right
here's the thing
all right if you want
is this what it was i think this was it
i think this was it
let me see
uh
yes this was it i went to overwinter
coffee in downtown buffalo
and they made just the perfect espresso
see i say that right i don't say
expresso i say espresso
um
it was [ __ ] amazing and nothing gets
my day going like that and that's the
same way i was saying the way you judge
your pizza it's it's it's uh
you get you got to get the plane you got
to get the margarita so they can't hide
behind their toppings same thing with
the coffee joint all right if they can't
make an espresso [ __ ] everything that
they're making in there that's what i
say
all right we know that's what you say
bill cause you just [ __ ] said it all
right relax all right that's the podcast
uh go [ __ ] yourselves and i will uh
check in on you on thursday